-Very exciting.
I -- I would -- Be honest.
If I knew that I was gonna have
an author of a book
called "GingerNutz" on, I don´t
know if it would´ve been you.
Why not?
-I don´t know.
"GingerNutz"
does not strike me
as the name of
a book you´d write.
How did you come to write a book
called "GingerNutz?"
-Um, well, I didn´t
actually write it.
My friend Michael Roberts
wrote it.
And conceived it, actually.
-So why isn´t he here?
[ Laughter ]
-Because you wouldn´t
have us on last week.
-That´s true.
There you go.
But how did this come about,
this book?
-Well, it was
a kind of silly story.
I was...75 a while back.
-Yeah.
And they were trying to throw me
a surprise birthday party.
-Uh-huh.
Do you like surprises?
-I love surprises.
-Oh, good, okay.
-Yeah, I do, fortunately.
Well, you know,
I always know
something´s hatching
when it´s my birthday time.
Anyway...
Um, they decided they were --
they´d like a nice invitation
to send to everybody,
which I knew nothing about.
And so they asked Michael,
who´s an illustrator --
Well, he´s everything.
But, anyway,
he´s an illustrator.
And they asked him to do
an invitation for the party.
-And this is the invitation
he drew -- for your 75th.
And that is, uh...
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
It´s wonderful.
-I think it´s wonderful.
But, apparently,
everybody thought
I would be incredibly offended.
-Okay.
Because it´s an orangutan
with very similar hair
to yours, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But anyway --
And I knew nothing about this,
and the whole invitation died,
and I think they just
e-mailed everybody or something.
I don´t know.
Anyway,
about three months later,
Michael suddenly
sent me this picture.
E-mailed.
And, actually,
I never look at e-mail,
but I did happen to see this.
And I said, you know,
"What the hell is this?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "You know,
it kind of looks like me."
And he told me the whole story.
-Okay.
And you were not offended?
-I absolutely love it.
I loved it.
No, and I said, "She´s got to
go somewhere, this girl."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, together we sort of
hatched up a sort of --
-And so that´s how
we ended with --
"GingerNutz" ended up
with a very similar story to you
in a very similar memoir.
-Well, actually --
[ Laughter ]
It was easy,
because Michael Roberts
actually wrote my memoir
kind of with me, for me.
-That´s fantastic.
-So he knew the story.
-And he knew
how to take that story
and put it on an orangutan.
-Yeah, and sort of
parallel it with --
-That´s fantastic.
-´Cause the whole story
is completely my story.
-You --
I first came to know you,
and I know a lot of people
in the fashion world
have known you forever,
but "The September Issue,"
which is an excellent
documentary about Vogue
and the inner workings
of Vogue.
And, you know,
not only do we see
sort of Anna Wintour at work,
but we --
I got to be introduced to you.
Was that a film that you found
a lot of people
then became aware of
who you are?
-Um, yes, yeah.
I don´t think anybody
knew who I was.
I mean, a few people
in the fashion business knew,
kind of knew me a little bit.
But certainly
nobody in the street,
or I was never recognized.
-And now, do people in the
streets approach you,
still from
"The September Issue?"
-Um, still, yes.
People are still seeing it.
It´s really incredible.
It´s on planes or something.
I don´t know.
-I remember watching it,
and for me,
it felt very similar to "SNL,"
in that it´s very --
the stress that goes into
putting together,
especially the September issue.
And I felt
a real connection with you,
because I felt like
Lorne Michaels
is a lot like Anna Wintour,
and your role, I felt like,
was very similar
to a head writer at "SNL."
Because they sort of
are very good at giving bad news
and then having
you go tell it to people.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
Yeah, like,
"Oh, those pictures are killed."
-Yeah, but then,
it felt like you were very --
you had the right personality
to do that,
to give people bad news.
Is that fair?
-[ Laughs ]
What gives you that --
-Well, I just mean,
you´re very sweet,
so I feel like you´d give to it
them in a way that´s easier.
-Oh, I´m not so sweet.
-You´re not, really?
[ Laughter ]
-I´m really horrible.
-You know what?
I´ve mistaken you
with GingerNutz.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-The very kind orangutan
who gives you bad news.